do you have an interview coming up if so
let's stop
welcome back to Udacity career tips my
name is marcin McGovern and this week we
are diving into career tip 17 record
yourself and ace the interview so you've
got an interview coming up how are you
practicing for it well I already know
that you're watching this video which
means you're at least doing your
research googling interview questions
listening to people like me these are
great first steps but at some point you
need to stop listening to other people
and start listening to yourself and I
mean that literally grab your phone open
up the voice record app find a list of
your favorite interview questions and
hit record how you don't phone as you
answer the list of interview questions
you're gonna stumble
you're gonna ramble you're going to mess
up but once you get to the end of the
list you're gonna have it all recorded
and this is important because most
people who practice in front of a mirror
or with friends tend to forget the
answers that they gave within 24 hours
of practicing for the interview
but since you recorded it you can
remember it and go back and improve it
follow this process a dozen times and
you'll be able to speak and think on the
fly tell stories that people want to
hear and most importantly stand out in
an interview you'll also get a leg up on
the competition because most people
according to science do not enjoy
hearing their voice outside of their
head but those of you who can overcome
that awkwardness and take on this
challenge will have the advantage when
it comes to your next opportunity so
give us a shout in the comments if
you're gonna try it I can't wait to hear
what you all have to say
thank you so much for watching click the
link in the description if you'd like
more career resources and tag a friend
who's looking for a job right now let
them know you're thinking about them I
wish you the best of luck in your search
and hope you have a great rest of the
week